or toujours en politique c'est cette
tribune de marlène schiappa quel psy et
dimanche dans le jdd qui avait
évidemment pour objectif de faire réagir
avec cette phrase notamment qu'on va
avoir à l'écran la république en marche
n'a pas vocation à diviser en courant
mai à élargir alors que vous veniez des
républicains d'europe écologie les verts
du ps ou du parti animalistes tout ce
qui nous intéresse c'est êtes-vous prêt
à faire passer votre pays
avant votre parti c'est un petit parfum
de kennedy et en même temps cet appel
patriotique ça vous plaît daniel
bilalian
moi je comprends pas tout mais non même
décidé comme ça que il n'ya plus de
droite ni de gauche et qu'il faut se
rallier
on marche parce que c'est le sens de
l'avenir non je suis pas d'accord moi je
pense que contrairement à ce qui a été
dit en 89
l'histoire du monde n'est pas terminée
c'est pas parce qu'il n'y a plus d'union
soviétique d'un côté capitaliste et et
communistes de l'autre que le monde
s'est arrêté il ya toujours il ya
toujours une il ya toujours une gauche
il ya toujours une droit je pense que
les événements de ces dernières années
ont été surtout je fait de la lyre
d'incident de parcours parce que
pourquoi aujourd'hui la droite se trouve
dans cet état là c'est qu'elle a perdu
ses trois leaders historiques en
l'espace de six mois en 2010 est fillon
juppé sarkozy et donc qu'ils ont du mal
à se reconstruire
je pense qu'aujourd'hui on parle du
retour de françois hollande à la tête du
parti socialiste je pense que s'il
revenait à la tête du parti se disent
peut-être se passerait-il quelque chose
malgré toutes les erreurs qu'ils
devraient moi je pense que décidé que
eux c'est le côté le la politique
aujourd'hui ce serait d'être pragmatique
c'est pas de la politique c'est d'être
pragmatique
c'est en libération je crois s'était
qualifié cette tribune de volonté
hégémonique voire de totalitarisme et de
parti unique totalitaire terme de
l'édito de libé ce matin ah oui bel et
bien de temps en temps d'hier le filao
puisque libé alors non écoutés cette
phrase elle ne s'applique pas à
l'ensemble des parties et ne s'applique
pas à l'ensemble des français c'est une
réplique à ceux qui veulent
explicitement une réplique à ceux qui
veulent organiser des courants soit à
l'intérieur de m soit à côté comme
existe partie agile faire un pendant à
gauche derrière que c'est le drian ou
d'autres on peut discuter est ce que
c'est une bonne idée ce que c'est une
mauvaise idée mais en aucun cas c'est ça
c'est la lune volonté de parti unique
d'abord c'est pas parti unique si on
veut créer des parties supplémentaires
ou des courants supplémentaires et ne
trouve pas ça ne vise pas la disparition
des partis d'opposition
le parti socialiste ou ce qu'il en reste
les républicains et les autres donc
c'est quand même mais la perte reste
sont abusifs de cette phrase parce que
tu y as passé a souvent de tête de turc
à une partie des médias etc la boîte
comment dire qu'est ce qui est
scandaleux
il ya déjà quelque chose de pas
scandaleux c'est de dire qu'il faut
préférer son pays à son parti bon je
pense que tout le monde est d'accord là
dessus le pays c'est plus important que
n'importe quelle partie ce qui moi me
paraît assez contestable c'est de dire
que si on préfère son pays à son parti
alors c'est le alors en marche alors il
faut rejoindre en marche
moi je crois qu'il ya des gens qui en
toute bonne foi préfèrent leur pays
aiment leur pays et vote communiste et
votre front national est votre
république à et votre socialiste c'est
pas parce qu'ils préfèrent leur parti on
a droit de pas être d'accord avec la
façon qu'ils ont d'aimer leur pays
mais dire qu'il aimait son pays c est en
marche et ne pas aimer son pays c est qu
on aborde tous les autres ça me paraît
une vision alors c'est pas totalitaire
un peu schématique pour être pas
complètement tort mais en même temps
chacun des autres partis disent que
c'est qu'il travaille c'est pour la
france mais c'est aussi le souvenir
demeure un parti qui incarne intérêts de
la france non mais c'est un parti dit
qu'il a quand même intérêt de la france
leur compte par contre à défaut il ya
des choix politiques
il ya des fonctions qui incarne
l'intérêt de la france et ce qui est
assez étonnant c'est que on utilise ce
type de formules généralement quand on
parle du chef de l'état c'est à dire
qu'on dit souvent un chef de l'état il
doit être capable de pouvoir
s'affranchir de son parti pour pouvoir
diriger un pays
objectivement j'ai pas être mesquin mais
c'est quand même assez cocasse que
marianne chapa donne cette leçon parce
que c'est bien d'une leçon qu'elle donne
au reste
du monde politique alors même que le
président macron a passé son temps à
faire la campagne des européennes en
s'affichant non pas comme au nom d'un
pays mais au nom de son propre parti
donc je trouve ça franchement à cet art
délicat
et la deuxième chose lisez la phrase
mais veut ni deux vous n'êtes pas que
vous soyez
ceux-ci ceci cela c'est pas vous devez
tout sera vraiment maintenant et vous
venez
que vous veniez de l air comme prononcé
que vos lions de vevo com parce qu'enfin
que vous veniez de ps comme didier
guillot êtes vous organisés pas au
courant mais pourquoi ça dit pas plus
que ça et pourquoi n'ont ils disent à
dire trois fois plus juste pour pouvoir
taper store [ __ ] ait pas d'accord mais
pas du tout et nous allons vous aider
énormément l'absolu mais je lui mets
mobiliser la tribune et vous verrez
qu'on dit et vous ferez affaires à faire
passer votre pays avant votre peinture
pour ceux qui viendraient de l air que
vous restez à l'air vous préférez votre
parti si vous êtes alors si vous
préférez votre nom mais ça c'est non
mais vous à l'interview saissac elle dit
en gros
arrêtez de rester dans tous ces vieux
parti qui ne défendent que leurs
intérêts de boutique
venez nous rejoindre nous embarque bien
qu'arnaud l'intérêt national parce que
william mc qu'elle s'adresse finalement
à ce qu'ils aient jamais séparé
d'assurance adresse à eux pour que cette
structure pendant mais voilà on peut
trouver quelques fois des arguments de
meilleure qualité et la deuxième chose
c'est olivier domaine c'est quand même
entendez que cette tribune intervient
pas dans n'importe quel moment les mêmes
nous on fait on fait toute la campagne
des élections européennes en expliquant
qu'il y avait d'un côté e ou le chaos
je veux dire la façon dont ils
construisent en permanence un débat
public un débat politique qui serait
structurée entre ceux qui ont raison
ceux qui sont qui défendent l'intérêt du
pays
ceux qui sont les seuls progressiste et
de l'autre côté les souverainistes les
passéistes
ceux qui ne quittent eux qui ne sont là
que pour des intérêts de boutique
objectivement c'est pas je ne crois pas
une bonne façon d'organiser le débat
public et c'est dans une excellente
occasion de passer cet extrait
dung
dominique reynié le politologue quitté
ce dimanche matin interviewé sur europe
1 voici ce qu'il dit vais sur cet
effacement de la droite et du personnel
l'effacement de la droite et du ps
parlant de la droite l'effacement de ces
partis qui étaient hier des partis
capables de passer de l'opposition au
gouvernement leur disparition fait qu'il
y à un face à face entre emmanuel macron
et marine le pen et que le temps qui
nous sépare de la présidentielle un peu
dégradée le rapport de l'opinion à au
président on sait que gouverner ça n'est
que des difficultés et donc l'absence
d'alternative modéré à droite ou à
gauche favorisera beaucoup l'arrivée de
marine le pen au pouvoir pour rebondir
et alexis finalement peut-on reprocher à
emmanuel macron de profiter des
faiblesses de ses adversaires pour faire
la politique non on peut absolument pas
le prochain on peut même pas lui
reprocher d'avoir créé ça c'est un
mouvement qui est dans tout dans tous
les pays occidentaux on sent que cette
polarisation sociale entre d'un coup tu
pour aller très vite les riches et les
pauvres entre ceux qui profitent de la
modélisation et ceux qui en souffrent
c'est partout comme ça vous avez raison
de dire il en a profité
il s'était inscrit là dedans donc il
s'agit pas de lui reprocher mais on
n'est pas non plus obligé de dire que
c'est un bien
on n'est pas obligé de dire que pour
l'avenir de ce pays c'est absolument
formidable qui est d'un côté les pauvres
et de l'autre côté les riches d'un côté
ceux qui profitent de la médiation et de
l'autre côté ceux qui en souffrent eux
et ont notamment obligé de dire parce
qu'à la fin les pauvres sont plus
nombreux qu'à la fin ceux qui souffrent
finissent par prendre le dessus et
qu'ils sont énervés d'avoir souffert
longtemps
donc c'est je crois moi que le principe
de la politique c'est de ces deux
justement de fédérer au delà des
antagonismes de classe des antagonistes
de revenus des hauts cadres 19 situation
sociale de bain de canaliser sa dans des
des discussions idéologiques politiques
qui ont sûrement plein de défauts qui
sont un peu schématique un peu parfois
absurde un peu mais qui ont le mérite de
précisément sortir de cet affrontement
purs et durs de classe qui s'il devait
durer mais peut-être qu'ils durent pas
parce que tous savent s'il devait durer
six devaient s'installer et
potentiellement dangereux on l'a
d'ailleurs vu avec les gilet jaune
c'est cette crise sociale elle est
réelle c'est une crise quand même de la
france d'en bas contre la france d'en
haut c'est à dire pour ça que la droite
a voté pour macron parce que toute la
partie bon
droite qui se sent à juste titre de
france on a eu peur de ça mais c'est pas
un avenir qu'on peut souhaiter pour ce
pays ni pour aucun pays d'accord avec
cette vision de la politique
le fait une étude qui avait été fait sur
ce terrain sur les sommaires et les élus
web c'est-à-dire il ya une partie des
gens qui ont envie d'appartenir ne se
refuse pas le monde moderne mais envie
d'appartenir à un pays à une
collectivité et les annuaires c'est ceux
qui travaillent 10 open space dans les
grands aéroports internationaux qui vont
d'un endroit à un autre
c'est ça on reste quand même dans ce
domaine dans ce domaine et les gilet
jaune même dans leurs outrances
ils sont ce sont des hommes auraient ce
sont des six nations poursuit le
raisonnement c'est emmanuel macron
meilleur tremplin de marine le pen pour
condenser sont d'abord les électeurs qui
sont les tremplins de marine le pen
pourquoi est-ce que la social-démocratie
réussit fort bien aux élections
européennes voire aux élections
générales qui ont suivi dans certains
cas en espagne ou portugal au danemark
en finlande
et pourquoi en france s'effondre à 6 %
où elle stagne à 6%
c'est quand même par emmanuel macron qui
décide que le ps va rester à 6% et que
marine le pen va être à 24% 1 c'est la
responsabilité première est la
responsable se situe à gauche par
l'incapacité de se doter d'un leader
reconnu par la capacité de se regrouper
en ans
entre les différentes chapelles et donc
mettre ça sur le maquereau ça n'a pas
beaucoup de sens moi je suis pas la
libye pour défendre macron dit par des
francia pas sûr quand vous vous obstinez
comme des fous sur une bouche avec un
marteau piqueur mais marteau pilon mais
sinon franchement
peut-être qu'ils en profitent peut-être
qu'il pense que ça la rend peut-être
qu'il joue avec le feu parce que en
effet un bonjour ça ne marchera plus
parce qu'un beau jour le plafond de
serre n'existera plus mais la première
responsabilité est déçu qu'ils sont
incapables d'en recueillir l'adhésion de
français jouent avec le feu le maximum
c'est quoi je suis totalement d'accord
avec vous et je retire si ça n'avait pas
profité à maquereau sera peut-être
inverser sa prophétie qu'on a soi même
chose que moi et me voilà une manière de
dire les choses mais il a surtout assuré
wassem en plus j'arriverai à trouver des
points de convergence et que mon voisin
c'est pas le problème là j'aimerais
juste vous indiquer que j'étais d'accord
avec vous mais en inversant votre
argument c'est que quand vous indiquer
que la social démocratie va mieux et que
ça
ça démontre le fait que le parti
socialiste en france finalement n'a qu'à
en prendre qu à 430 qu'à soi-même
j'aurais tendance qu'elle m'a indiqué
que françois hollande a mis
effectivement son quinquennat mis par
terre le parti socialiste français
on ne pouvait pas lui considéré qu'il
avait mis à bas l'ensemble de la social
démocratie européenne
or l'ensemble da social démocratie
européenne aujourd'hui est épuisé il se
trouve que dans un certain nombre de
pays il y à des rebonds et il se trouve
que ces rebonds ils sont bien une chose
assez simple qui était posée d'ailleurs
pendant le qui n'a pas pu être posée en
france pour les élections européennes
c'est que les gens n'attendent pas de
l'europe des pour ou contre l'europe ce
qui était le débat qui était portée par
les bannières marquant qu'un débat
dangereux
la question qui était posée cs de quelle
europe on veut et on peut être de droite
est pour l'europe et on peut être de
gauche est pour l'europe
et comme on politise pas le débat
européen depuis de trop nombreuses
années la réalité des choses c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on nourrit la
désaffection européenne est sur moi j'ai
pas de problème a considéré qu emmanuel
macron est un grand européen
il est un grand européen qui étaient
contre le congé parental européen il a
le droit et je pense que les socialistes
sont des grands européens qui étaient
pour le congé parental on n'a jamais pu
avoir cette discussion là pourquoi on
n'a jamais pu avoir cette discussion là
parce que le débat il s'est focalisé
entre ce que vous êtes pour ou contre
l'europe et bien la fin dont ce type de
scénario vous le savez bien
quand il ya des grandes coalitions il ya
une disparition clivage comme une
disparition clivages les gens ils
décident à un moment donné de changer et
ce sont les populismes qu'il empoigne
elle gagne l halloween qui on regarde il
ya une évolution dufournet de l'ex front
national du rassemblement national sur
les problèmes européens ils sont pas
aujourd'hui contre l'europe
ils sont contre l'europe telle qu'elle
fonctionne aujourd'hui marine le pen a
fait évoluer et peut-être que ça ça lui
a attiré un certain nombre des vecteurs
parce que qu'est ce qui se passe sur
l'europe qu'est ce que nous reprochons
nous à l'europe simple citoyen c'est que
sur des grands sujets comme
l'immigration ya toujours pas de
décision vraiment efficace en revanche
sur la taille des fromages et les aoc
alors là on est on est très très très
fort c'est ça c'est ça que nous
ressentons et en politique faut jamais
partir de la vérité c'est pas à me
bouger de ça il faut partir de notre
impression
nous on a l'impression que cet organisme
qui est l'europe ne s'occupe pas des
problèmes essentiels qui devrait régler
au nom des heureux chers amis
gagnant assez souvent aussi on invente
un monstre européen qui n'existent pas
parce qu'on est en train de vous refaire
le coup là sur les camemberts et
l'histoire de l'accord entre les
producteurs de camembert au lait cru
enfin le salon déroulé cru qu avant
pertes autorisé le droit d'appeler
camembert on essayait l'europe
recommence je veux cuivre terroir et le
camembert au lait cru
alors que ça n'a aucun rapport ni de
près ni de loin à l'est que c'est très
bien c'est une négociation
interprofessionnelle réussi les salles
et la russie et enfin qui est parvenu à
cet accord et la nomura il me pense que
camembert s'est éloigné de nous mais
notre sujet initial pensez vous comme
marlène que les élus les républicains et
du ps devrait faire passer leur pays
avant leur parti
la question était posée ainsi vous êtes
65% à dire que oui
donc nos internautes selon kotch
ils passaient leurs pays d'abord mais
pour les intérêts du rdpc qui restent
les publications des makrouts et les
états y penser dès leur pays font pas ce
qu'ils détestent leur pays qui ont des
coaches me disent ce qu'ils pensent
d'abord pays demeure au sein des
républicains web pour leur assemblée
nationale et ceux qui ne pensent qu'à
leurs intérêts personnels se ruent vers
en marche et la vie de coach
babineau dit c'est intéressant l'idée de
de chiapa madame schiappa profite de la
disparition du clivage traditionnel
gauche-droite makrout nous pousse à nous
positionner 1